Okay, so today I am going to show you an absolutely
outrageous and baseless Donald Trump lie,
but I'm going to do something else. I'm going
to show you the Genesis of the lie. I'm going
to show you the evolution of the lie, how
it becomes more and more dishonest over time.
And we in a sense w to quote Donald Trump,
we're going to look at the oranges of this
lie or as I like to call them the origins
of this lie.
So Donald Trump spoke, uh, yesterday, I believe
it was. Maybe it was late on Monday and it
was complete diarrhea of the mouth. I mean
just endless lie after lie after lie. I'll
give you the most sort of cartoonish lie first,
which we'll be focusing on, which is that
when Donald Trump became president, the military
was out of ammunition. I know that may come
as a surprise to many of you in the audience
who are aware of how much money we spend on
the military, but Trump's claim is the military
had no ammunition when he became president,
but he fixed that. Take a look at this.
Aye, we all together you. We defeated and
took over 100% of the ISIS caliphate. Everybody
said that was going to be an impossible thing
to do. I did it and I did it quickly because
we have a great military now. When I took
over our military, we didn't have ammunition.
I was told by a top general, maybe the top
of them all, sir, I'm sorry sir, we don't
have ammunition. I said, I'll never let another
precedent have that happen to him or her.
We didn't have ammunition. Now we've captured
ISIS. We've done what we've done. We had 50
soldiers in the area you're talking about.
By the way, no one said it would be impossible
to defeat ISIS. That that's like another lie.
When the, uh, when the Obama administration
was getting ready to exit, I said many, many
times and so did others that we are sort of
on a trajectory for at least with regard to
its territory, the caliphate is some like
to call it of ISIS. We are heading towards
the destruction of that. The question will
be how do we deal with radicalized cells that
are disconnected, but whether it was Hillary
or Trump, what Trump is talking about, the
elimination of the caliphate was likely to
happen either way. I said it, many people
said it, but Trump says we had no ammunition
when he became president. He fixed it and
now low and behold we have captured ISIS.
We'll get back to that. That's the lie. I
will show you the evolution of, but a few
other choice lies by Donald Trump from very
strange speech. Donald Trump claiming of course
with no evidence that his poll numbers are
up 17 points in the last three days. Now when
he says his poll numbers, does he mean hypothetical
2020 polling? Does he mean approval polling?
We never know. And of course the reason we
never know is because it is made up. He has
nothing to back this up. It's obviously untrue.
This is a scam and the people are wise to
it. And that's why my polls went up. I think
they said 17 points in the last two or three
days. I've never had that one.
Yeah, so no, I mean that just, it didn't happen.
And then here is Donald Trump saying total
falsehoods about Adam Schiff. These are even
less coherent. Like these are, it's more difficult
to even understand what allegations Trump
is making here. But they're all very much
untrue. Take a look.
Adam Schiff should be investigated for what
he did. He took to the great chamber Congress
and he made a speech at his speech was a fraud.
Everything he said was a fraud. He won out
as though I wrote it. He defrauded the American
people. He defrauded Congress, he defrauded
himself and his family. He made a speech as
the horrible speech. I said, what is this
guy? What's going on here? I think he's having
some kind of a breakdown because he got up
and made a speech. That board no relationship
to what the conversation was.
You can tell Trump is kind of making it up
as he goes along, and none of that stuff is
true. So let's go back now to the ammunition
claim. Let's look at the oranges of this lie.
Uh, where did Donald Trump's lie that the
military was out of ammunition until Trump
fixed it come from to begin with? This is
the Genesis of that lie. The evolution of
the bogus story. I think you'll find this
interesting. So of course it's not true that
the year Trump became president, the U S military
was out of ammunition. In 2016, the U S spent
more than $600 billion on the military. Much
of that went to ammunition. We had plenty
of ammunition already. Although it is true
that Barack Obama had slightly trimmed the
amount of military spending in some areas.
Okay. So Donald Trump's stories started with
way back then when I met with general Maddis,
he came to me and he said, we are low on ammo
now.
We don't even know if that's true. Right.
It's possible that it's totally made up. It's
possible that nadis went to Trump and said,
listen, we are behind on the accumulation
of a certain type of ordinance. It may not
even have been. Again, if it's true, it may
not even have been because Barack Obama wasn't
spending enough money. It may have been a
supply issue. It could have been, who knows?
Right. But it started with Maddis came to
me and said, we are low on ammo. Trump has
then exploded the military budget. So it's
probably true that Donald Trump has spent
a lot more money on ammunition. Trump took
that story, which may have a kernel of truth
in it or it may not, like we don't even know.
And then expanded the lie to say, well, Maddis
said we have low slash no ammunition. Okay.
That was he modify. He always has to go to
the next step. Here's Trump expanding it too.
It wasn't just low, it was low slash no ammunition.
The story for the first time today, a general
came into my office and my first few weeks
you remember it was a little dangerous out
there. President Obama left us with a few
beauties, right?
[inaudible]
you said to this general, you better be prepared
because this is looking like it could really
be conflict. And he looked at me and he goes,
sir, we have very little ammunition. I said,
say it again and I want to tell you the words
very little. He didn't use because it was
less than that and I said, I never want to
see a president in a position like that. Well
we may have conflict and a general looks at
him and said, we have very little slash no
ammunition. I never want a president of the
United States to be in that position.
Okay, so is supposedly saying we are low.
We don't even know if that's true. Becomes
Maddis said we are low slash out of ammunition.
Okay. This is the first evolution of this
lie. Then four days later, Donald Trump upgrades
to, we had no ammunition at all.
I've rebuilt the military. We've, uh, Scott
and I were talking about that we spent one
and a half trillion dollars when I came in,
our military was depleted. Frankly, we didn't
have ammunition. Okay. But our military was
in very bad shape
and then now in about a one month period,
it all becomes, we had no ammo and I fixed
it. I got us ammo. And because of that, I
was able to defeat the caliphate of ISIS in
the middle East when again, the kernel of
possible truth is maybe Maddis said we were
low, possibly about some particular kind of
ammunition. Unclear if it's because of anything
Barack Obama had done, right. Could have been
a supply issue, could have been anything.
And that possible kernel of truth becomes
Trump endlessly repeating that we had no ammunition
and he got us ammunition. And that's the ammunition
that was right, by the way. Ammunition, right?
I mean like when an unsophisticated term to
even be using that is the ammunition that
got us the defeat of the caliphate of ISIS
in the middle East. Thanks to the great Lord
and savior Donald Trump, the Genesis of ally.
Okay. Understand how works. These people will
stop at nothing. He will say anything. It
doesn't matter whether it has a grain of truth,
a kernel of truth or not. Question for you,
do you believe that Donald Trump has convinced
himself that the latest, most extreme version
of the story is true? Or do you think that
Trump knows that he is exaggerating this story,
which possibly is not [inaudible]
based in any actual reality? Let me know.
I'm on Instagram at the Pacman. If show is
on instagram@davidpakmanshowthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com
welcome back